bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france alors
loyalistes et indépendantistes vous
monter la pression sur l'état les
premiers pour qu'il maintienne le
référendum sur l'indépendance à la date
du 12 décembre le deuxième pour le
report un bras de fer qui s'annonce
compliquée quelles conséquences
justement pourrait avoir
voilà ce référendum si les
indépendantistes ne participent pas au
vote
alors aujourd'hui ils ont annoncé qu'en
plus de ne pas participer il ne
reconnaîtrait pas les résultats futurs
efforts de ce référendum ce qui était
étudié des prévisibles à la question
c'est de savoir
si cette question si cette contestation
par dont elle aurait une portée
juridique politique ou simplement
médiatique est tout simplement quelles
seraient les outils ou levier juridique
à disposition 10 dans l'évent dentiste
pour contester concrètement le résultat
du prochain référendum alors du côté du
ministère du loto mais on est plutôt
serein le vote et la participation c'est
une liberté chaque chaque électeur du
corps du corps électoral spécial vote
aura ou pas en son âme et conscience
la question que l'on se pose plutôt
c'est au niveau de l'international on
rappelle que la mecque et demi et
réinscrite sur la liste des territoires
onusien à décoloniser non autonomes à
décoloniser et l'onu suit ce processus
de décolonisation depuis l'accord de
matignon en 1988 et même deux ans
auparavant de la réinscription de la
mécanique sur cette liste et les
indépendantistes on tombe bien je pense
mené 1 les communications lobbying au
niveau de l'onu dans que halak witt de
l'international et comment et qu'un
conclusion si heureusement les
observateurs internationaux de cette non
participation puisque comme ce fut le
cas en 2018 en 2020 il y aura des
observateurs internationaux avec et demi
en décembre ont tous des styles eux si
le référendum est maintenue le 12
défendre ce qu'on ressent également une
certaine réticence de la part
voilà de la population elle même pour
aller voter le 12 décembre prochain
alors au final on a vraiment
l'impression que ce ce pour ou contre le
maintien du référendum au au 12 décembre
mais ressemble beaucoup aux débats jeux
traditionnels pour ou contre
l'indépendance sylvia
la france dans l'indépendant tisci et
pour son maintien et la france
indépendantiste qui est contre son
maintien la question c'est
l'inconnu aussi c est ce que les les
militants
indépendantistes vont finalement suivre
les consignes des
chefs indépendantistes c'est quand même
une position qui est assez difficile
quand on a appelé à un vote à se
déplacer à participer au premier au
deuxième référendum et que aujourd'hui
on appelle à ne pas participer il ya
c'est quand même une position difficile
en tout cas ce débat pour ou contre le
maintien du référendum
s'est renversée c'est le même débat
qu'on retrouve pour ou contre
l'indépendance on ne verra ni dans que
les clivages sont su marquer là dessus
alors les indépendantistes qui évoque
justement la dégradation de la situation
sanitaire on sait que le gouvernement
doit trancher en fin de semaine la date
d'ailleurs du 12 décembre et pas fait
consensus entre les loyalistes et les
kanaks parce que finalement c'est voilà
cette situation sanitaire qui va aux
quelque sorte motivé la décision de
paris à votre avis
alors oui et le ministre d outre-mer l'à
plusieurs fois répété qu'ils ne seront
que s'il ya report ce sera sur critères
objectifs et sanitaires et là on voit
quand même clairement une notable
amélioration de la situation sanitaire
de l'accueil de nuit le taux de
vaccination a beaucoup monté on dépasse
aujourd'hui les 60%
de la population vaccinée qui affiche un
schéma vaccinal complet et
aujourd'hui le virus est en passe
vraiment d'être d'être bien contrôlé et
il est selon les prévisions il sera
normalement sicile à la compagne du coup
de vaccination pardon elle se poursuit à
ce rythme 80% de la population pourrait
être vaccinés le 12 décembre donc la
situation femmes sanitaire s améliore la
question c'est aussi est ce qu'il ya un
risque de recrudescence on l'a vu en
2002 2018 et surtout en 2020 lorsque la
nouvelle calédonie n'était pas confinée
qui avait pas de masque on devait gagner
il y avait beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
monde au bureau de vote à aujourd'hui le
commissaire a quand même annoncé d'aidé
des adaptations pour permettre en reste
et des gestes barrières mais c'est quand
même un vote qui a beaucoup beaucoup
mobilisé en 2018 et 2020 donc
effectivement il ya il y a quand même je
risque de recrudescence mais quand même
là là
l'épidémie est aujourd'hui bien maîtrisé
merci beaucoup en tout cas j'attends des
photos d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes journaliste à
outremer 360